i'm told by sources that prey too is not
just inevitable but
already in the works so
if we did get a sequel to this brilliant
movie what would it look like and how on
earth could it even work
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so if you are regular to the channel you
know that i adored this movie prey was
just great i loved how it was a
stripped-back version of things we've
seen recently for predator it was a far
simpler version in many ways and it was
beautifully made i thought it was well
written i absolutely loved the naru
character i thought she was really well
worked i know a lot of people have been
quite angry about this movie i will
almost certainly get woke comments
but for me
it was just this side of realistic it
was reasonably believable as believable
as really any action movie can be
and it just
worked but
it also did very well for hulu their
biggest opening thing ever disney plus
are also very happy with the numbers
i bet they're regretting not releasing
the cinema now and a sequel is already
being talked about the people i talk to
that the work in the industry are saying
it's not just being talked about it is
happening
and there is no no question um the only
real question hanging over it because
this was already discussed before the
movie came out was how good would it do
and it did very well so all we're really
waiting for is the eyes to be dotted the
t's to be crossed and this is happening
so the culture of the yatua is something
that's been really well fleshed out
mostly through comic books graphic
novels and um lots and lots of stories
we know a lot about them the prey
movie gave us something
a bit new and a bit fresh you know the
feral predator
this predator from 300 years ago was
something that we hadn't quite seen
before and it was a little bit different
to me i think this was actually an
unblooded when we first see the predator
i don't think it's a
predator that has ever killed anything
before and i think that's very clear
from the movie how it starts poking
snakes and things
so if you don't know an unblooded is
basically a baby predator it's a
predator that hasn't really killed
anything yet a blooded predator is one
that has killed at least one xenomorph
we saw that in avp when the alien was
killed by the predator and he marked
himself in his helmet marking himself as
blooded within the culture of the yahwah
they basically haven't killed anything
you're
nothing you have no status in the
society
but to become an elite predator
according to the graphic novels and
things you have to have killed an alien
or xenomorph queen to become a clan
leader or really the the pinnacle except
for the elders the really pinnacle of
the yahwah culture you have to have
killed an alien hive this is 300 plus
xenomorphs plus the queen with only two
predator mates to help you there are
actually then beyond that the ancients
now the ancients are apparently an
incredibly rare
part of the culture of the yahwah and
these are predators that have survived a
thousand years and really are the top
the absolute pinnacle of their culture
now i'm telling you all this because we
already know this about the yahweh or
the predator species
but there's so much more we could learn
from a really good prey sequel
don't forget to hit the like button
share the video wherever you like and
subscribe also if you enjoy the content
please become a fully fledged side
tracker hit the join button for us
now the one thing we 100 do know about
the predator movie is that the pistol
the raphael
adolini 1715 and
flintlock pistol is going to be really
important because we know at the end of
predator 2 that that's the trophy they
give to danny glover so at that point in
the late 80s early 90s the predators
have that pistol
but at the moment naru's got it so
in the sequel the easy thing to do will
be the predators come back to
find out how this young predator was
killed by a weak little feeble woman
and they hunt her down kill her take the
pistol that's the easy option and a lot
of people have already said that that's
not going to happen is it because naru's
too popular a character they won't kill
her off that would really upset the fans
and i'm like now that would be an
awesome ending to the movie for two
reasons we've never actually seen a
movie where the predator wins i'd like
to see the predator win
um but also i mean that could be
dramatic as hell you know she fights and
fights this has that hero's death that'd
be awesome
but there are a couple of other theories
about how the movie could go if they
didn't go that way
in the comic books there are occasions
where humans have been so successful at
battling against the predators that they
actually then get brought into the clans
so they basically become a predator
themselves
now there is one story out to say that
well maybe that's something they they
could do and that she would be taken
from the earth and actually end up going
and fighting um or hunting with the
predators on other planets
but i can't see that
it it doesn't make sense to me because
of the style of the prey movie the one
of the reasons why this movie is so good
is that it is a stripped down version
it's not got all the bells and whistles
of avp requiem or the predators even
it's a simplified boiled down movie and
that's one of the reasons why it works
so well they're not going to just flip
that completely on its head for the prey
sequel and just have something
completely different but is there
another possibility
well you could argue that prey is
actually a remake of the predator the
original the classic they have lots of
little nods to the original movie
throughout and you know i think in lots
of ways that's a fair assessment
so what if they now
remade or did a sort of rebooted version
of alien vs predator now in the prey
movie we've seen the final sequence the
animated bit at the end and in the
animated at the end we see three
predator ships reappear as the tribe is
trying to leave
we know from avp that they did used to
come to earth with
xenomorph eggs alien eggs and use humans
to spawn the aliens and then hunt them
maybe we could see that happening
and we could actually see
nauru fighting alongside the predators
against xenomorphs
now to be honest i think that's got
really cool possibilities
but
if you thought it was ridiculous that
nara was fighting a youngling predator
wait until you see what happens if they
try to have naru versus a xenomorph
alien
that is gonna have to be managed very
very well if that's gonna work because
it could look really silly really
quickly
either way though i genuinely think
naaru has to die in the next movie she
has to die bravely and in a way that the
predators really respect because they
then hold on to this trophy this pistol
for
300 years for me
the only way the pistol could have that
much weight and be that special to the
atwa is if she did something really
really incredible now if she's already
killed a feral predator
maybe next she actually fights alongside
the predators against an even more
terrifying enemy the xenomorph aliens
but guys what do you think what do you
want to see and pray to which again like
i say as i'm told is almost certainly
happening get in the comments and tell
me exactly what you think also if you
are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification it
really helps us out also if you enjoy
the content don't forget you can become
a fully fled side tracker and give us a
little bit of contribution each month
that really really helps us out
as always guys please stay safe and i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you